hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grandla waifu and today we're
all about those poor choices
my poor choices your poor choices their
poor choices i i have no idea if you've
made poor choices but you know no one's
perfect so let's talk about choices
shall we
knuckle not allowing shoot the freedom
to give his life to the cause resulted
in two
problems when i think about it the first
one is that knuckle is putting the plan
at risk and going very steeply of course
in a way that could get shoot killed
anyway
secondly the fact that shoot has reached
his pinnacle as a person and feels
amazing about this decision has now been
stolen if something happens to knuckle
as a result of his own failure to abide
by the plan
shoot will be damned to a life like a
short life in fairness
but a life of guilt and self-doubt of
course i'm not saying it's good that
he's feeling particularly suicidal but
in a world where he's in a life or death
situation
feeling okay with the death part seems
pretty good for mental self-preservation
there are a lot of negative things i
want to say to knuckle that
aren't necessarily fair but go something
like this back off dude don't be so
selfish there are more important things
at stake more egos to stroke and
more needs to fill than your
self-aggrandizing selfish need for
everything powerful or good
in the world to focus on you in the
worst possible way your inability to
manage
your emotions and ego could literally
bring about
the end of the world follow the damn
plan
if a couple of teenagers can do it in
the face of huge doubt
it's not too much to ask that you do it
too which brings me to a new question
who decides which abilities and then
user gets
i know they can try to build around a
concept but beyond that because
realistically
knuckle is sort of like cheeto all he
has to do is
not let his opponent touch him and he
can't even do that
it's an odd comparison to make but it
just annoys me so much when characters
who should be capable of levels of
behavior don't display it in this moment
i felt grateful to and impressed
by shoot stepping up as a personal
member of clan human
if all knuckles saw was his weakness and
that he would eventually fall
it says more about knuckle and shoot who
has clearly reached the pinnacle of his
ability and was prepared to do what
needed to be done for something greater
than he
i'm glad he's alive don't get me wrong
but i'm annoyed by knuckles interference
in this moment which is
coincidentally exactly what kilwa didn't
do right
gone is still in death monster he's
locked onto his external gone and that
kilwa is scared for his friends
says he clearly hasn't been paying
attention to now because what i see
is the inside gone coming out and i'm
impressed he held it in so long
not only that but looking back i'm
honestly kind of surprised that he's
throwing this sort of rage
revenge monstrosity type being at
someone because of what they did to
someone else he met and vaguely got to
know
as a friend of his dads a few weeks back
i don't know that kite
kind and thoughtful though he was is
worth this level of anger
more than that like with knuckle and
shoot i don't think kite would
appreciate that gone has turned into
this monster in revenge it's another
case of selfishness when you think about
it
interestingly it does probably bring him
closer to the person his dad wants him
to be given his dad only wanted to meet
him if he turned up alone but still
is kite specifically worth this level of
revenge in some ways
as the pinnacle of goodness that we have
as in hunters
to this point yeah sure absolutely but
in others
and more ways more practical ways no if
kiwa died i would expect this
i would expect a rampage because kiwa is
gone's property
more or less kite i guess kite belongs
to his father if we want to look at it
in the same way but it still doesn't
hold
enough weight for me maybe i wasn't
invested enough in the relationship that
form
or maybe it's the fact that kite's name
hasn't even been mentioned as the reason
for gone's rage for 10 episodes or so
if not more how we talk about things
tells us a lot about how we feel about
them and the absence of talk also says
some if this were truly for kite
someone would have mentioned it trained
or not he's a teenager
focused or not after this i wouldn't be
surprised to find out that gone's the
next big bad
even an image of kite you know like i'm
still thinking about this even an image
a flash of remembrance anything to show
us that there is an
emotional center to gon's blankness and
we don't get it and he didn't even
consider kilwa when kilwa splitter
friendship here to gone
means nothing if kilwa gets in the way i
actually expect kilwa probably
to be a casualty or close too so why
kite
i don't think it makes sense enough to
do it this way or at least i don't think
it was
defined enough or or put into place
strongly enough
to be worth this and of course kilwa as
a character is far too human despite his
weird stabby hands that make him
distinctly not human
to sink to gon's depths but let's see
what happens in
episode 115 episode 115
and kite has been mentioned by the
narrator but by this point i'm even less
convinced that gone
is trying to save kite or avenge him in
any way i'm not sure why i'm so
distrustful of god's motivations
could it be the fact that he left a
friend to his fate that he didn't care
at all what happened to killa yes we
could argue that he trusted his friend
to be capable of looking after himself
but
it doesn't look like he even spared a
thought for the poor kid who gets
soft-eyed and concerned whenever he's
around
not in the same way that icalgo does
we'll get to icargo i'll be back
hold on there octobuddy i'm coming for
you not to mention that same kid who's
supposed to be a friend has
found his grandfather not ask questions
he should have and has been noted by
that same granddad to have changed
significantly since he's left home
it's kiwa i'm talking about killa kirwan
needs more attention than he's getting
from gone specifically gone needs to
take a look at cure gone needs to take a
look at gone gone needs to just like
stop stop hammer time just stop
dude no in fact no hammer time no hammer
time for you let's look at keela
his eyes have depth to them now that
they didn't have before and i guess
that's what the point of the kind of
creepily overly realistic eyes they're
in frame they weren't creepy but like
given
it was animated it just felt like it was
too much detail gone doesn't care
gone is angry and has found the source
of his anger which is all that matters
to him there's nothing pito will be able
to do to stop him and if kilwa doesn't
do something to stop
gone little queenie there will
definitely die maybe they could strike a
deal instead get grandpa and his dragon
balls involved maybe
meanwhile knuckle decides to play cat
and mouse with a wacky inflatable
flailing arm man with extra eyes and not
only do i think that was an
awful idea but i'm not sure exactly what
he stands to gain from having done that
since both characters are absurd with
their every little helps mentality
it's not that every little doesn't help
but if that's the best he had my grumpy
rant from the last episode grows only
grumpier because it becomes
even less likely that anything useful
will come of the interaction
stepping back and looking at it as a
whole i found this episode to be a
little bit too
scattered for my liking and honestly the
last one as well as much as i like to
know what everyone's doing at any given
time and i do enjoy knowing how the
times mesh together
it can become too fiddly after a while
to deal with that fact without becoming
fluttered and like yeah
and i think this was the point at which
the story is sort of the story needed to
find a very specific
important thread and hone in on it
arguably that's the wolfy boy arc that
we've been brewing for a while and
it's nice to have side stories that can
complicate matters but tagashi is
fantastic at complicating matters
without cleaning up threads for example
what happened to the phantom truth or
kite's annoying team or cult strange
baby or piggy there's a lot that tagashi
gets
briefly involved in before getting
distracted and i get it i'm
also highly distractible but sometimes i
feel like he needs someone you know
an actual editor perhaps to say no more
gone till you finish your kurapika or
something because with so much open it's
possibly why i've struggled to connect
and invest in god's motivations if
they're not
intended to be an arc of how to become a
full-time monster wolfboy is a similar
situation
his sudden existential crisis was
relatable but the fact was that it felt
contrived because tagashi wrote himself
into a corner ikalgo and that other bro
can fight it out and either one could
conceivably survive while keeping the
story narratively interesting if a calgo
and wolf in about cross
paths icalco would lose immediately and
while it would be a big
outcome it wouldn't be narratively
interesting because we know what their
abilities are from a survivalist
perspective so welfan had to have an
epiphany rather than
smelling octobuddy which he most
certainly should have been able to do
given his level of paranoia
and scenting even without the
realization that hagia
was the wrong name on that i was
pleasantly surprised to find that
despite my obvious difficulty with names
as soon as octobuddy said hagia
i was waiting to see if they would
notice the inconsistency having
something pointed out and signposted so
clearly meant that i could
easily follow that point and i kind of
wish some of the other points would that
clearly signposted in some way
not so that i get there before the
characters do but so that i get there at
the same time as them it's a very
careful balance to run and i was only a
few beats ahead which meant i got to
enjoy the realization
that actually his name's leo i've got to
have that realization at the same time
that kind of serendipity is a technical
craft and one that hunter hunter seems
to struggle with at times either we get
too much information
and the story gets bogged down or we
don't get enough and things come out of
nowhere or out of a chunk of information
that was given in long-form
prose episodes and episodes points once
we got through that awkward moment go to
wolfboy for literally having paranoia as
his men attack but i'm not sure i'm
happy with the amount of narrating that
needed to be done to
set the imagery up there's a lot of
telling rather than showing that's it i
like the premise and actually seeing
wolf do do something nanny which i don't
feel like i've seen before and now we
get to
the mvp of the episode which was truly
meleoron chameleon camilan camilan's
butt was the mvp of this episode as he
power walked his way through the palace
of all the arcs in play at this point in
time it's that chameleon arc that's
given me sweet sweet tension and i'm
finding myself
leaning more and more heavily on the
storytelling involved in his journey
than
anyone else's besides it's hilarious
seeing a panicked chameleon in a
tracksuit power walking i don't know
it's one of those innately amusing
things and i didn't realize
it was something i needed in my life
until like when i saw it overall
these episodes showed the highs and lows
of the arc which of course makes sense
you need to drip tension and ooze it out
and let it go
in order to raise it you can't keep
people constantly high or they'll make
their own fun and start
laughing at things you don't want them
to my problem with right now is that in
choosing where to drop the tension
takashi seems to forget that by jumping
from scene to scene
he's actually trying to prop the tension
up and then
complicating matters light and color can
only be interesting for so long before
it becomes a wash so i'm hoping that in
the next episode we actually get to stay
in one place with our primary
protagonist for a bit
to see if that's the case i need to
finish up here and drink this smoothie
so that's it from me
if you enjoyed this casual ramble click
here here and here maybe
over here don't forget to like share and
subscribe and i'll see you
next time